Prof: Last time then we
talked about the cantos of
pride.
We introduced the cantos of
pride: X, XI,
and XII.
I was arguing that Dante comes
to know and understand the
virtues and vices of pride and
its opposite,
humility, which he sees
featured--humility he sees
featured in Canto X and pride
he'll see punished in Canto XII.
He gets to understand the
nature of this virtue and this
vice by looking at the work of
art.
So that in Canto X,
we already have a sort of
representation of what an
aesthetic education can turn out
to be.
How do we look at art and what
are we likely to learn from it?
This was the argument.
Dante arrives into Purgatory
proper and the first image that
uses to give us a sense of the
dimensions of this place is the
figure of the human measure.
He measures the world around
him through the dimensions of
the human figure.
Obliquely, it's not quite--we
are not quite there yet to that
point,
but he's warning us that indeed
the issue--
what is the issue about pride
and about humility really is--
what is the man's measure?
We are--he says that he's going
to--
that the place is measured
according to the size of human
beings,
but then the question is what
is the measure of human beings
in a moral sense,
of course.
Since pride,
superbia in Italian and
in Latin, is a sin of excessive
love of one's own excellence.
The sense that one isn't quite
reducible to what perhaps others
see about us.
The idea that there may be a
touch of vanity in the way we
judge and view ourselves,
the way in which we measure
ourselves.
Humility, on the other hand,
is the opposite--
is the remedy to pride and it
is really a virtue in that it
really reduces us to--
reminds us of the fact that we
are earthbound.
That's the meaning of the word,
and by the way,
that's exactly how humility and
the etymology of human are
connected.
They're both derived from a
common root, a common matrix in
humus which is the Latin
word for the earth.
We are called humans,
homo,
because we come out of the
earth, because we are made of
the clay of the earth,
and we return to the earth.
That's the other implication.
On the other hand,
humility is the virtue that
reminds us that we really should
not view ourselves as all that
elevated.
So these are the issues.
Dante then confronts some
scenes of humility.
He begins with the virtues,
and the sins of humility--the
virtue of humility are all taken
from the three histories that
interest him.
He's always placing himself at
the confluence of these three
strains of history.
An image from the Old
Testament, David,
who dances in front of the ark,
therefore he humiliates
himself.
He tells us that he's more and
less than king.
By the way, this phrase
"more and less,"
this lack of precision is
really an expression that
pervades Canto X.
This "more and less,"
the grief is "more"
than I can take,
etc.;
it appears in a variety of
forms, at least five times in
the context of the canto.
Next to David,
and that image of humility from
the Old Testament,
and above him actually,
watching down from the balcony
of a high tower in the royal
palace,
there is his wife Michal,
who looks down at David.
Not only she looks down at
David, she obviously has
contempt for him,
because in her view he is
humiliating,
he's offending,
violating the principle of
decorum of what a king ought to
be.
She has a different
understanding of what is the
measure of a king and the place
of a king, because pride is
exactly a question of place.
What place do I occupy in the
world around me?
Am I where I think I would like
to be or am I where somebody
else is placing me through
his/her gaze?
The second image is an image
of--but they're all--
you'll notice the little
detail, they're all placed
above,
they're sculptures placed above
the normal sight,
so that there is obvious
reversal now in what the value
of humility can be.
There is the story of the
Annunciation,
the angel Gabriel who descends,
literally,
and that descent is a story of
humiliation of the divine,
the divine enters history,
and therefore in that sense the
divine is truly omnipotent.
There is the idea which is
really something developed,
I mention it here,
but I will come back to that,
the idea that the divine is
detached from the human would
make the divine less omniscient.
A divine that does not know the
human, does not know death,
cannot claim to be omniscient.
That's an argument that Dante
uses.
So there is the story of the
angel Gabriel who comes down and
the obedience of Mary,
the Virgin Mary,
who says, 'Yes,
I am your servant.'
So there's a story of--and Mary
is the one who said to turn the
key between the old alliance and
the new alliance.
She reverses the story of Eve.
It is as if her obedience is a
response to some kind of
violation and the promise of
being divine in the eating of
the tree.
The third example,
or story, that the pilgrim
sees--
looks at--it's the story of the
emperor Trajan,
secular history,
who stops his--from marching
onto his campaign into Dacia,
into Romania,
in order to give justice to a
little widow,
the diminutive is Dante's.
A little widow who has been
asking for justice before he
departs, justice for the death
of her son.
This is what he--what Dante is
confronted with and what he is
confronted with is we do know
that he's being asked and
directed by Virgil to look at
the whole scene,
not to stop at one detail,
to even move beyond Virgil
himself,
in what would appear to be a
transgression of the reverential
bond that ties them.
He--Dante is always following
as a disciple follows the
teacher.
So he just even transgresses
his place but that doesn't seem
to have anything to do with the
aesthetic education of the
pilgrim.
He's witnessing what he calls
visible speech,
synesthesia.
That's why this phrase it says,
visibile parlare,
in Italian, visible speech.
It's a synesthesia that
combines the sight to sensory
experiences, the eye and the
hearing;
so speech because this is God's
art and God's art has also a
precise meaning.
A precise meaning that Dante
has no difficulty understanding
or finding delight in,
so this is the argument.
At one point,
in the drama of the canto,
some figures keep appearing and
Virgil directs Dante's eyes
toward the people that are
appearing.
Dante does not recognize them.
He says, I don't know what they
are.
My sight is so confused.
He doesn't want to even know
who they are or what they are.
Virgil will explain to him they
are human figures crawling on
the huge boulders and almost
moving like,
on the ground,
on the earth like worms on the
earth.
And Dante is not really capable
of deciphering them or having
even sympathy with them.
At that point,
as you recall,
because I had the feeling that
maybe the explanation is a
little bit--
was a little bit too wriggly,
but Dante's poem--
canto moves in that way with a
lot of sinuosities there.
I mentioned to you a particular
passage in Chapter II--Book III,
Chapter II of the
Confessions.
It's an extraordinary passage
and I brought it in so that you
can--I want to read a little bit
from that.
It's a passage--it's a book
where Augustine is living in
Carthage, you know.
At about now,
at this stage he's about 17,
19--has been talking about his
attraction for shows,
his attractions for the
Manicheans,
the distaste for scripture that
he has,
and how he is going to be--has
been led astray by some of his
friends with the stealing of--
gratuitous stealing of the pear
tree--
the pears from the pear tree,
which he doesn't understand why
he would ever do that.
And now he talks about once
again his experience of the
theatre.
That is to say,
he's discussing his experience
of himself as a spectator,
which is exactly what Dante
was.
Dante--the problem Dante in
Canto X of Purgatorio is
that he is at first a spectator
of works of art,
which he seems to have no
difficulty understanding.
Then he has to be
involved--show them at least
some compassion,
some self-recognition with the
souls who are these shades,
penitents, who are under these
huge weights that they carry,
and he cannot do it.
He still has to learn what
grief is and what is it,
and how do you go on connecting
to the images that you see.
Let's see how--what Augustine
says,
Augustine is--that's what he
says: "Stage plays,"
this is really Chapter II of
Book III,
"stage plays carried me
away,
full of images of my miseries,
and a fuel to my fire.
Why is it that man desires to
be made sad?
Beholding doleful and tragical
things which he himself would by
no means suffer."
The real pleasure of his going
to the theatre,
he claims, we have a great
pleasure, is in the images of
grief.
They don't really touch us,
we are not even expected to
jump on the stage to relieve the
characters were involved in this
sort of situation.
He goes on, and then you'll see
what the point is,
"which would himself by no
means suffer,
yet he desires as a spectator
to feel sorrow at them,
and this very sorrow is his
pleasure."
I was just paraphrasing that.
"What is this,
but a miserable madness,
for a man is the more affected
with his actions.
The less free he is from such
affections, however,
when he suffers in his own
person, it uses to be styled
misery.
When he feels compassion for
others, then it is mercy.
What sort of compassion is this
for feigned and scenic passions?
For the auditor is not called
on to relieve,
but only to grieve,
and he applauds the actor of
these fictions the more he
grieves.
And if the calamities of those
persons were of all times or
mere fiction,
to be so acted that the
spectator is not moved to tears,
he goes away disgusted and
criticizing,
but if he is to be moved to
passion,
he stays intent and weeps for
joy."
This is an extraordinary
passage, I think,
in the history of antiquity and
the criticism of the theatre,
dramatic theatre.
The point is,
can we ever be disengaged
spectators?
Yes, we can be disengaged
spectators and Augustine is
criticizing the disengaged
spectator,
the belief that we can be in
front of the play of the world
and that things only touch us,
as if in a fiction,
and yet we ourselves are not
going to be able to acknowledge
it.
He's really criticizing the
limits of the theatre,
the limits of that kind of
aesthetic experience.
I think that Dante is picking
up exactly from this--what
Augustine says in this chapter,
and he's showing how
unavoidably one has to be
involved.
There's--in the measure in
which we think that we are not
touched by somebody else's
grief,
we're really admitting the
overpowering quality of that
experience.
That's his argument.
He has learned something then;
he has learned that there is no
such a thing as a safe
perspective.
The way--and he has learned
what Michal had been doing in--
from the high window of her
palace,
that she was expressing disgust
at her husband because that
offends her own sense of
superiority.
Dante says, I may be no
different from Michal in my
disclaimer that I do not know
and I do not see any of these
penitents who disfigure the
human form.
In refusing to acknowledge that
they are like me,
and refusing to have any
self-recognition between me and
them.
This is really the aesthetic
education.
Let's see now how for Dante it
is aesthetic and it's ethical.
He goes on understanding that
the stakes are in the idea of
perspective,
the idea that the world is a
projection of my own wishes and
that world is really
reformulated.
If I think that I can take a
safe distance,
it's because I do not want to
look within myself.
Canto XI and Canto XII,
I think, will answer that
question.
Let me just go on with Canto
XII--Canto XI,
I'm sorry.
First of all--if there are
questions you can interrupt me,
because I don't think this is a
difficult argument,
but if there are questions
interrupt me now or keep them
for later.
Canto XI begins with the
penitents, who now change,
reverse perspective.
They are so close to the
ground, but they are looking up,
and they have the Lord's
Prayer, in what is Dante's own
recasting of the canonical
prayer.
"Our Father,
which art in heaven,
not circumscribed but by the
greater love Thou hast for Thy
first works on high."
This is the prayer of the
penitents.
"Praise be Thy name and
power by every creature as it is
meet to give thanks for Thy
sweet effluence;
May Thy peace of Thy kingdom
come to us, for we cannot reach
it of ourselves,
if it come not,
with all our striving.
As Thine angels make sacrifice
to Thee of their will,
singing hosannas,
so let men make of theirs;
Give us this day the daily
manna, without which he goes
backward through this harsh
wilderness who most labors to
advance;
And as we forgive everyone the
wrong we have suffered,
do Thou also forgive in
loving-kindness and look not on
our deserving;
Our strengths," and so on.
"Thus beseeching good
speed for themselves and for us
those shades went beneath their
burden,"
etc.
What about this prayer?
First of all,
how is this related to what we
are talking about?
The first thing is that in the
Lord's Prayer,
the change Dante makes is to
emphasize that God is not in
space, not circumscribed.
God is not in space and
therefore He is really
everywhere, or He is free.
That formula he is using,
you may want to know,
is a traditional one in
medieval thinking whereby God is
said to be an infinite sphere.
This is a formula to define
what--the idea of the infinity
of God.
An infinite sphere whose center
is everywhere and whose
circumference nowhere.
God is not in a place;
God does not have a perspective.
There is--indirectly there is a
critique of perspective here,
or the inadequacy of a
perspective.
God is everywhere,
not circumscribed,
that's the first change.
The second change that he's
making,
this is a neo-Platonic element
that he adds on to the Lord's
Prayer,
and then the second one is that
he literally places,
"Give us this day the
daily manna,
without which he goes
backwards,"
he literally makes the Lord's
Prayer the prayer of the exiles
in the desert.
Like the Jews in the wilderness
who ask and get their manna,
so now this is another element
that--
another metaphorical element
that casts Purgatory as a
journey through the desert
between the bondage of Egypt and
Jerusalem.
The other point is that there
is a reversal of perspective
somehow, and what kind of a
perspective is he gaining now?
The perspective,
I think, is what I call a
Franciscan perspective.
Let me just explain first of
all, the line,
"Praised be Thy name and
power by every living
creature."
This is literally an echo of
the first poem of the Italian
poetic tradition,
a poem written by St.
Francis, which is known as the
Canticle of Creatures,
which is really a sequence--a
anaphoric sequence of praises.
'Praised be Thy name,
praised be the water,
praised'--and so on.
The point of that poem is that
it begins with the look of human
beings up to the highest and
then it ends up with the idea of
humility.
We are, Francis says,
"Not the most important or
the center of creation,
we are like everything else
valuable in creation."
That's the thrust of the poem,
and the only way in which you
can really understand the
creation is really to look from
the bottom up and not from the
top down.
This is the true,
the kind of perspective that he
is describing in the poem.
The rest of the canto really is
a connection between art and
pride,
which we are not going to be
surprised,
since the whole of Canto X was
a reflection on the premises of
that--
of the two metaphors,
art and pride.
So you have the illuminators
and then references on lines 90
to the painters,
"O empty glory of human
powers,
how briefly last the green on
its top,
unless it's followed by age of
dullness!
In painting Cimabue thought to
hold the field,
and now Giotto has the cry,
so that the other's fame is dim
and so..."
And then the poets,
Guido Cavalcanti and Guido
Guinizelli: "So has the one
Guido taken from the other the
glory of our tongue,
and he, perhaps is born that
shall chase the one and the
other from the nest,"
meaning Dante himself.
The idea of fame,
which is what the proud souls
may be looking for,
is here dismissed as having the
inconsistency of the wind,
just vanishing like the breath,
a breath of wind,
and so this is the sort of
moral understanding of pride and
humility.
In Canto XII,
I just want to show you and
describe the reasons why,
and try to explain to you the
reasons why Dante deploys a
peculiar rhetorical artifice.
And I ask you to turn to around
lines 25 which is a sequence of
new visions Dante has.
This time the images are on the
ground.
So he has to look down;
he doesn't have to look up,
and they are images of the
proud souls who have been
punished and therefore now they
appear now on the ground.
The text starts,
"I saw him that I was
created nobler than any other
creature,"
now of course you know who he
is,
"on the one side;
I saw Briareus,"
one of the giants,
"pierced by the heavenly
shaft, lying heavy..
.I saw Thymbraeus,
I saw Pallas and...
I saw Nimrod...
" All figures you have
more or less seen before.
"...
at the foot of his mighty work,
as if bewildered,
and he was looking at the
peoples in Shinar that shared
his pride."
And then four tercets:
"O Niobe..
.", "O Saul...
", "O mad Arachne...
", "O Rehoboam...
" And then,
once again, the four more
tercets: "It showed too,
that hard pavement,
how Alcmaeon...
It showed how his sons fell
upon Sennacherib...
It showed the destruction and
the cruel butchery that the
Tomyris wrought.
...
It showed how the Assyrians
fled in rout after Holofernes
was slain."
And then one final tercet:
"I saw Troy in ashes and
in heaps;
O Ilion, how abased and vile
the design show thee that we saw
there!"
These are all the figurations
of punished pride:
pride that has been now
literally humiliated.
I did have to ask you to look,
so that you can understand the
artifice.
This is what we call a visible
speech that Dante himself has
been deploying,
and to do this I have to ask
you to look at the Italian text
that begins with the word--
every tercet with the letter V,
though I'm sure you would like
me to read a little bit of the
Italian: Vedea colui
che...
, Vedea Brďareo,
the next tercet Vedea
Timbreo, next Vedea
Nembrňt.
And then, the four next tercets
with the letter O:
O Niobč,
O Saůl,
O folle Aragne,
O Roboam.
And then the next four tercets
with M, Mostrava ancor..
., next Mostrava come i
figli si gettaro..
., Mostrava la ruina...
You've got to read down,
Mostrava come in
rotta...
and then final tercet from line
61 to 62, Vedea Troia...
o Ilion..
mostrava il segno...
which sort of recapitulates all
of the key elements of this
artifice.
We are in the presence of a
so-called acrostic that if you
read from the top down,
it spells the following V-U-M
and then recapitulates.
This is the V,
but in Italian it's also the U.
That is to say, the fall of man.
So he's doing this--he's using
this artifice that you can only
understand if you read the text.
If you have to hear it,
you can't quite get to it.
In other words,
he's doing two things,
using God's own art as a model
for himself.
This is pride,
it would seem to be pride.
After all it's excessive love
of one's excellence,
but God did that in Canto X,
he's going to do the same thing
now with the text.
The second thing that it shows
is that the text is not a text
to be just heard,
it's a text to be read.
It's a text to be looked at.
It's what we call visible
speech.
What is Dante doing in--is he
lapsing into a sin of pride?
Of course, but what he's
telling us is that pride is not
a sin.
He is, in a sense,
redefining the ethical language
of the Middle Ages and the
ethical language of his own
text.
He's saying that in the measure
in which you love what is above
you, that is not a sin.
The sin--it is a sin,
pride, in the measure in which
you do have contempt for those
that you think are below you.
We have, thanks to the world of
art, a re-evaluation of the
moral language.
That's the first and most
important example of all of this
that happens throughout
Purgatory in Purgatory itself.
Do you see what--is it--do you
want me to say this again?
Dante, by imitating God's form
of art as he does here,
with his own text,
he's drawing attention to this
as an artifice available to us
thanks to his text and it's only
possible to view it the way he
describes it within the text.
He's giving a peculiar status
to his own text.
This text has also its stages
and artifice that we normally--
and he has learned from God
directly,
which means that the sin of
Lucifer,
even, is not just the sin that
he transgresses what's above
him--
it's the sin because he has
contempt for what is below him.
So the humility and pride
really have to go hand in hand
and one attenuates and changes
the meaning of the other.
This is really something that
in many ways a Franciscan
canto--
you might want to write a paper
on that on the song of the so
called--
the Song of All
Creatures by St.
Francis and this particular
canto.
And so you may draw your own
conclusions, if you do not agree
with what I have said.
Let's move on to the next few
cantos.
I want to go to,
above all, to Canto XVI because
here we have--we are approaching
now the center of the world of
Purgatory.
We are in the--we skipped envy
altogether and I will get back
to that on another occasion in
Canto XV,
but in XVI and XVII we'll talk
about anger,
the sin of anger,
the purgation of anger.
Here, in XVI,
Dante meets a famous
magnanimous figure called Marco
Lombardo and he has a discussion
about human--
he has a discussion with him
about the so-called--
the issue of human degradation,
of human degeneracy.
The scene takes place in a kind
of--
the cloud of anger,
the biblical cloud of anger,
sort of a world deprived of any
light,
a kind of madness,
if you wish,
anger understood as that which
violates the clarity and light
of reason that--
as we refer to it.
"Gloom of Hell or night
bereft of every planet under a
barren sky overcast everywhere
with cloud never made a veil to
my sight so heavy or of a stuff
so harsh to the sense as the
smoke..."
And then the language:
"Just as a blind man goes
behind his guide that he may not
stray or knock against what
might injure or perhaps kill
him,
so I went through the foul and
bitter air listening to my
Leader."
He meets then,
within this context,
in this background of a
cloudiness and near blindness,
near invisibility of the world
around him.
The kind of invisibility that
has been carried over from the
sin of envy, which as you know,
is all about being blind.
Then he hears a voice and Dante
asks one question.
The question is:
do we have the "world is..
.wholly barren of every
virtue,"
on line 55,
"as thou declarest to me,
and pregnant and overspread
with wickedness,
but I beg thee to point out to
me the cause that I may see it,
and show it to men,
for one places it in the
heavens and another here
below."
Is there such a thing as free,
what we call free will?
What is it, what is free will?
What is the cause of all our
deeds of our doings?
Is it--as the astrologers will
say, in the planets and
therefore a matter of
determination by forces that
transcend us and which we have
no control?
A severe limitation of the
meaning of choices and the
possibilities of choices,
and therefore of merits and
demerits.
If we have no choices,
then we can really--we cannot
be praised or blamed for what we
do, or is it within us,
and this is Marco Lombardo.
It is a revisit--Dante's
revisiting the whole story of--
and debate, an ancient debate
about the relationship between
free will and God's
foreknowledge if you wish,
that Boethius in The
Consolation of Philosophy,
as is well known,
had been confronting.
"He first heaved then a
deep sigh,"
line 63 and following,
"which grief forced us to
'Alas!',
then began: 'Brother..."
I don't have to point out to
you, this is the form of
salutation in Purgatorio.
You already had "Our
Father" in Canto XI,
with this idea that there's a
human family,
therefore a brother is the
appropriate form of
interlocution and address among
the souls and Dante.
"..
.the world is blind and indeed
thou comest from it.
You that are living refer every
cause up to the heavens alone,
just as if they moved all
things with them by necessity.
If it were so,
free choice would be
destroyed."
I think the text is very clear.
I would have to tell you that
there is a distinction between
choice and free will,
they are not the same thing:
free choice or free will.
And this is a very difficult
argument because choice implies
that we--that it's an
intellectual problem,
that we choose thanks to what
we know.
The will is a difficult
argument, because free will
implies that the will is never
in bondage,
and it's possible to attain the
moment where we will freely.
In fact, so many theologians go
on asking that free will means
that the will finally can be
moved by an act of choice that
it is--
it follows on the prior act of
knowledge.
Dante uses the two terms:
"if it were so free choice
would be destroyed in you and
there would be no justice and
happiness for well doing and
misery for evil."
That's the answer that Marco
Lombardo will give.
"The heavens initiate your
impulses;
I do not say all,
but, if I did,
light is given on good and
evil,
and free will,
and if it bear the strain in
the first battlings with the
heavens,
then, being rightly nurtured it
conquers all.
To a greater power and to a
better nature you,
free, are subject."
Which in Italian it really is,
I have to say,
more of an oxymoron,
line 80: liberi
soggiaciete.
You are free subjects exactly,
you are--and you can--you do
sense the--you understand the
contradiction in the two terms.
That is to say,
we are free,
but at the same time we are
subject.
I can only understand it
with--in terms of what Dante
will say a little bit later when
he discusses--
he shifts the argument to the
law, saying that that's really
the--
we are free subjects and the
law is exactly the--
the metaphor for him that will
make us understand what it means
to be free and subject at the
same time;
where limitations are going to
be posited and within those
limitations we can be free.
That's the argument.
"And that creates the mind
in you which the heavens have
not in their charge.
Therefore..." etc.
Then here the first thing that
Dante does is give a sense of
creation.
He posits human freedom in the
act of creation of the soul.
This is, "from his
hand," lines 85,
"from His hand,
who regards it fondly,
before it is,
comes forth,
like a child that sports,
tearful and smiling,
the little simple soul that
knows nothing."
This is the famous poem,
for those of you who remember a
little bit of Latin,
Hadrian--of the emperor Hadrian
about the little simple soul
that goes wandering around and
Dante's reinterpreting it as not
the soul that is lost in the
world,
but a soul that is playing.
The creation is a playful act.
The soul is a like "a
child that sports tearful and
smiling,
the little simple soul that
knows nothing,
but, moved by a joyful Maker
turns eagerly to what delights
it."
We have the idea of creation as
a free and playful act.
Play in the sense of the
innocence of the experience and
play in the sense of being free.
Now when one is at play one has
all the attributes of
spontaneity and freedom that go
with it.
It is the basis of what I call
the playful theology of Dante.
God creates the world in an
act--in a moment of freedom and
that freedom becomes the
foundation for positing our own
human freedom.
It's because we were born free
that therefore we can go on
believing and--that there is
such a freedom for us.
That it was not an act of
necessity--
that would be the opposite in
the moment of creation and the
experience of creation--
but it's spontaneous and
playful.
Then the canto goes on with
these extraordinary political
arguments, political and legal
arguments.
So we talk about human freedom
and Dante moves to political
freedom and look at what he
says: "Rome,
which made the world good,
used to have two suns,"
which is a kind of Baroque
image and I'll explain that too,
in a moment,
why he uses this image,
"which made plain the one
way and the other,
that of the world and that of
God.
The one has quenched the other
and the sword is joined to the
crook,
and the one together with the
other must perforce go ill,
since, joined,
the one does not fear the
other.
If thou dost not believe me
consider the ear of corn,"
etc.
What is he talking about?
God has--Rome had two suns?
The phrase translates--the line
mistranslates--
deliberately mistranslates,
a line in Genesis where it is
said that God gave mankind two
luminaries,
the sun and the moon,
but whereby we could really see
both in the day and at night.
This little image from Genesis
was used by the so-called
hierocrats,
the Canon lawyers of the middle
ages,
to explain it as the emblem for
the Empire and the Church.
That the Empire--the sun having
the larger light the hierocrats
would claim,
was the light of the Church,
and the moon having a reflected
light was the light of the
Empire.
It was an argument,
they would use this gloss as a
way of explaining the
superiority of--
the Empire over--the
superiority of the Church over
the Empire.
The Empire had to take its
light and its direction from the
Church.
Dante is deliberately violating
that idea of the sun and the
moon,
equating them by saying
"the two suns,"
in order to convey his
conviction,
the conviction that the two
institutions God provides for
the guidance of human beings,
the Church and the Empire,
are equal.
He's conferring on them an
equality rather than a
hierarchical ordering of the two
luminaries, the sun and the
moon.
It's an argument that really is
addressed against the lawyers at
the University of Bologna where
they are--
they were working for the pope,
explaining the sense of the
superiority,
the superior status of one
above the other.
With this whole argument here,
now the--
which is about a kind of
legality or the questions of
history's boundaries,
that's what I understand by
legalities,
you have retrospectively also
some light shown on this claim
of being free subjects in Canto
XVI.
We turn now to the very center
of the Divine Comedy.
The center of the Divine
Comedy,
which is, clearly,
numerically the center,
Canto XVII, and we'll see
how--what is it that Dante
discusses here in Canto XVII.
The canto--its visions of anger
of the--
the canto begins with an
apostrophe to the reader's
memory: "Recall reader,
if ever in the mountains mist
caught thee for which thou
couldst not see except as moles
do through the skin,"
the difficulty of sight,
the difficulty of seeing is
highlighted again,
"how, when the moist,
dense vapors begin to disperse,
the sun's disk passes feebly
through them;
and thy imagination will
quickly come to see how,
at first, I saw the sun again,
now near its setting.
So measuring mine with the
faithful steps of my master,
I came forth from such a fog to
the beams which were already
dead on the shores below."
It's a twilight landscape;
you have a number of reversals
and contrast--
antithesis actually the
mole--blind mole,
that burrows underneath the
earth and then alpine scenery
which makes vision also
impossible.
Dante's evoking the heights and
the lowest possible point of
sight with the mole.
The sun is setting and the
night is approaching.
It is as if the whole--so the
solidity of the world around him
is vanishing--is disappearing.
What's the experience?
At this very moment,
he's appealing to the memory of
the reader and the imagination
of the reader.
It is as if that when the world
outside seems to be failing us,
we have this--part of this
inner light,
this inner possibility of
recollection of the world or
imagining the world.
He's specifying what some of
the claims about the inner
lights that he says we have
within us could be.
He had just said that.
Also he's preparing this
extraordinary second apostrophe
to the imagination.
Dante is--we are approaching
the center of the universe,
this poetic universe,
and Dante reminds us that this
is a work of the imagination.
Why does he do this?
What is this--what does he say
about the imagination?
The first thing that he says
about the imagination:
"O imagination,
which so steals us at times
from outward things that we pay
no heed though a thousand
trumpets sound about us,
who moves thee if the senses
offer thee nothing?"
It's the same question he had
been asking earlier:
where do our choices come from?
Why do we what we do?
Is it because a power from the
outside moves us,
or is there something that is
within us?
Now this question is asked in
slightly different terms,
in terms of the imagination.
The imagination is a power,
that's what he--the way he
describes it--that removes us
from the outside world.
There's such a power--in other
words,
it's not just the imagination
that translates sensory
experiences into images for the
benefit of rational judgment:
this is the triadic
Aristotelian order;
the imagination has the middle
ground between the senses,
the work of the perception and
the work of reason.
This is a triadic pattern that
Dante could have found in
Aquinas;
we, in turn,
found it certainly in
Aristotle, that's the way it
precedes.
He has another imagination that
he's talking about now,
an imagination that removes us
from the outside world.
It frees us--it needs nothing
of the world of perception.
It is a power that,
in many ways,
steals us from it,
it's a power that--how does he
describe it?
It comes "from the outward
things that we pay no heed
though a thousand trumpets sound
about us."
It's a faculty that is
completely free from the outside
world, a power that we have
within us to imagine worlds that
don't even exist.
To imagine things that without
the solicitations of what lies
outside us and continues:
"a light moves thee which
takes form in the heavens,
either of itself or by a will
that directs it downwards.
Of her impious deed..."
and then he goes on describing
three images of anger.
At the point in which Dante is
approaching the center of the--
his world where this--where we
are witnessing,
we are shown the power of the
imagination as a visionary
faculty.
As a faculty that is not a
transcription of the real world,
and one wonders why he has to
make this kind of claim.
It encompasses the real world
and yet is something that almost
prophetic, something that does
not come from the contacts with
the world.
I'll come back to this in a
moment, I hope.
He has three images,
then three--that come down to
him gratuitously.
They seem to have been
descending into his mind without
anything that--around him and
then Dante goes on here
describing the law of Purgatory.
What is the world of Purgatory?
How is it constructed?
What's the architecture of this
world?
Unsurprisingly,
this is a fabric of love,
an architecture of love,
and it's at the very center,
lines 91,92,
and 93--that this is the actual
numerically even,
in the center the poem--not
surprising,
that's what Dante says,
"Neither Creator nor
creature,
my son, was ever without love,
either natural or of the
mind."
That's the center.
What does he mean natural or of
the mind?
He's distinguishing here
between the two types of love
and in fact he will clarify:
"..
.and this thou knowest;
the natural is always without
error," whatever impulse we
may have,"
that's the impulse of love,
that is never prone to
sinfulness.
It's a natural impulse,
a natural desire,
that which is instead sinful is
the one where choice is
involved.
"The natural is always
without error,
but the other may err through a
wrong object or through excess
or defect of vigor."
Whenever we make a choice we
may either not love the right
object or we may love it too
much,
or we may love it too little,
and so this is the topography
of Purgatory.
This triadic division in terms
of love.
Everything is a problem of love
but then there are varieties
that organize its subdivisions.
"While it is directed on
the primal good and on the
secondary keeps right measure,
it cannot be the cause of
sinful pleasure;
but when it is warped to evil,
or with more or with less
concern than is due pursues its
good against the Creator works
his creature.
From this thou canst understand
that love must be the seed in
you of every virtue and of every
action deserving punishment.
Now since love can never turn
its face from the welfare of its
subject all things are secure
from self hatred...
" and so on.
And Dante now responds:
"Now I would have thee
give thought to the other,
which pursues its good in
faulty measure.
Everyone confusedly apprehends
the good at which the mind may
be at rest and desires it,
so that each strives to reach
it, and if the love is sluggish
that draws you to see or gain
it,
this terrace,
after due repentance,
torments you for that.
Other good there is..."
The question then will
become--and I did not ask you to
read this canto,
but I can give you a sort of
brief preview of it--
Dante has to ask if--what is
this love of choice?
Does it depend--since I may
have a particular perception of
the world that makes me see
whatever I encounter as
beautiful and desirable,
where is my fault?
He repeats the same problems
that he's been raising in Canto
XV.
Dante will try to explain it in
terms of love,
and yet, we are going to be
brought back to the world of how
do we perceive what it is that
we love.
The perception of what we love
becomes crucial to our very
responsibilities for it.
So this is--at the center of
the poem then Dante seems to be
suspended between two ideas.
On the one hand,
the notion that there is a real
world where you have
responsibilities for everything
that we do and on the other
hand,
a world where there's an
imagination which is completely
disengaged from the world of
reality,
and cannot quite be constrained
or held in.
So how are you going
to--suspended between these two
possibilities--how is Dante
going to bring them together?
You see what the issue is?
How do you--if the world of the
imagination is free and
disengaged from reality then how
am--
I'm going to,
on the other hand,
going to be held accountable
for what I do over the world,
and with the world around me,
and with my own deeds.
At the center of the poem
Dante's raising this
contradiction that's
not--imagination is made to be
the way to knowledge.
I can only know through the
imagination.
The imagination of--that
depends on my perception of the
world or an imagination which
frees me completely from the
world,
and then these two ideas of the
imagination are really in
contradiction one with the
other.
So where is the human
responsibility?
The poem gets nourished by this
duality of the imagination.
The poem moves back and forth
between one and the other.
And let me just stop here
because I think I may have said
a little bit too much about
these issues and I could respond
to your questions,
I hope, if there are some.
Please.
Student:
So just as sins of the Inferno
were more products of the will,
the sins in Purgatory are more
products of love and he's not
told where will may or may not
have been factored into it,
and because Purgatory is the
place that's in between,
is it also the place of that
uncertainty between will and
love?
Prof: Well I don't know
about that.
The question is really a
perplexity about what I have
been saying.
In Inferno, will is crucial and
you are absolutely right.
There cannot be a sin unless
there is a will involved.
In Purgatorio,
the argument here seems to be--
the way I have been following
it from Cantos XV,
XVI, XVII and the way it's
going to be developed in XVIII
and actually frankly XIX,
where Dante goes on telling a
dream--
Dante makes the word of love
the crucial act of our being in
the word,
relating us to God,
we are related to God,
really born through the way of
love,
therefore, the way of the heart
and not unnecessarily through
some abstract metaphysical
issues.
Then the issue becomes how is
this love related to the will?
Is Dante being uncertain
between the two?
What is the moral--Dante begins
in Canto XV talking about moral
responsibilities,
this kind of free subjection
that we have,
and an inner light that is
available to us.
Then he--Canto XVI we'll also
talk about the--
in Canto XVI he talks about
creation,
the creation of the soul,
the freedom with which God
creates and that freedom
authorizes us.
It becomes a sort of ground for
the human freedom.
Then in XVII,
first of all,
he talks about an imagination
which is completely free of any
contact with the world and then
talks about this theory of love,
that rational love that
organizes, the love of knowledge
that organizes everything.
I could just have stopped there
and shown you,
this is really what the text
says, and maybe ask you to
connect imagination and love
that I read at the two sides of
Canto XVII,
at the very center of the poem,
almost to imply that we can
love only and so far as--
and we can love as well as our
imagination takes us to loving.
That's clearly one of the
images.
But clearly there is more in
that debate.
The debate is that if I love
according well,
or not enough,
or too much,
that has to do with the way I
perceive the world.
Why does he have to talk about
an imagination which is so
unbounded that it needs nothing
of reality?
I mean to say this that in the
subject and I call it--I say
well this is a visionary aspect
of the imagination.
It's a poet who thinks of
himself as being the visionary
poet.
You have an idea of Romantic
poets,
for instance,
English Romantic poets who
distinguish between fantasy and
the imagination,
though Dante does it in terms
of this imaginative power that
removes me from the world of
reality.
It takes me away and opens up
new spaces and the mind in
itself.
I ask this question though from
another point of view,
which I think is connected to
what we have been saying here.
Can Dante ever write this kind
of poem by being bound to the
world of reality and to the way
in which the real world is
known?
Clearly the answer is no.
The only way that Dante can
come to God and the vision of
God is by agreeing with this
idea,
yielding, surrendering to the
power of the imagination that
will take him out of the real
world.
You cannot really write a poem
like the Divine Comedy by
following rules and laws,
whether they are rhetorical,
or whether they are just pure
ideas of style.
You try to--you have to go on
imagining things that don't
really--are available to our
perceptions.
That, to me,
is the issue,
that's how I have been moving
this issue.
I think that the poem,
that Dante's voice is suspended
between these two possibilities
of the imagination.
An imagination that has to
accept the world of reality,
an ordinary imagination,
and yet there is also another
idea of the imagination,
which is so much more powerful.
But, if we accept this as being
true for the poem,
it follows we have to ask the
question of, what about the
moral life?
Is the moral life then one that
where Dante's saying,
that in effect,
all the language of blame and
praise,
which depends on accepting
limits and free subjection to
rules,
is that--is he saying that that
is also--
maybe it's arbitrary?
That there may be some other
law that he has to discover?
I don't think that there is yet
an answer here,
but that's the problem that I
was trying to convey.
Does that answer
your--provisionally--your
perplexities,
okay.
Yes.
Student:
Regarding Canto XVI with the
vision of anger served--the
beginning of anger that served
as a polar opposite condition to
love, why does he think anger?
Prof: The question is
does the sin of anger in Canto
XVI, is that a kind of polar
opposite to love?
Student:
And why does he begin with it?
Prof: Why does it begin
with that?
Well I think that anger--I
would define it as a form of
madness to begin with.
It's a kind of eclipse of all
rationality and so it explains
why Dante will have to go on
retrieving the laws of reason,
the laws of rationality to be
opposed to the kind of--
to that--the experience of
madness in Canto XVI.
We go into Canto XVII and he's
talking about a sort of love
which is very rational,
but then he is undoing it with
something that stands between
madness and love,
and that's the imagination.
See the connection?
Okay.
Student:
I'm a little confused about
what you just said about how the
moral life might present a power
to the imagination--I just think
if--what if an understanding
from what you've been saying
about why you use the
imagination is because you're
approaching mystery so it's hard
to use the real world to
approach this.
So it seems like--and so you
need the imagination and I guess
if Dante is going to God,
so if he's approaching
mysteries, so it's hard for him
to talk about this in a rational
language.
But isn't that more of like an
acknowledgement of his
limitations than a
transgression,
so doesn't it still fit with
humility and fit with the moral
life?
Prof: That's an
excellent point.
You not only asked the question
I think that you are clarifying
some of the problems.
The question is still about the
whole issue of the imagination
that on the one hand the
imagination seems to be the way
to so large and so--
such a force that will take
Dante, I'm paraphrasing your
point,
take Dante all the way to see
God.
I seem to be saying that that
is a kind of transgression,
but you emphasize that that can
be an acknowledgement of human
limitations.
I call it--maybe that's true,
that's really what it is.
It's--I call that a visionary
power within him.
It may be coming to him from
the outside.
He asks that question,
does this visionary power come
to me from the outside,
or is it something that is
within human beings?
That's the question.
He doesn't answer that question
at that point.
What he does say is,
well this is the image that
came to me, the image of a
martyr who committed suicide,
and he goes on with his three
images.
He doesn't answer that directly
and I think that he wants to
keep you guessing if this is a
human transgression or an
acknowledgement of human limits.
He--I don't think that he knows
yet, at this point,
what the unfolding of that
dilemma will be.
He wants us to think in terms
of that dilemma and that dilemma
is at the heart of Purgatory.
The dilemma between what is
this power?
I have a power within me
that--without which I can never
really go to God,
and is this in any way a
transgression?
Do I need a transgression in
order to come to God?
Ulysses thought that there
would be no knowledge without
transgression.
Maybe Adam in the Garden also
thought that there would be no
knowledge without
transgression--that the real
knowledge is to transgress.
Is Dante thinking that way?
Or maybe he's thinking that
there is no transgression
without, at the same time,
a sense of the limitations.
That indeed,
that the idea of transgression
depends on some sense of
limitations.
Do you see what I'm saying?
What the argument seems to me
could very well be,
that in effect pride and
humility are really more
connected than what we like to
think.
We are always proud and Dante
would say, it's good.
To me that's what Canto X,
XI, and XII were saying.
You may not agree with that
reading, that pride is good in
the measure in which I can reach
out for something really higher.
That's not bad.
What is bad is that that blinds
me to something else.
I take that to be Franciscan
thinking.
He is invoking the humblest
voice of the whole literary
tradition up to this time,
the Canticle of all
Creatures.
I'm glad that you are giving me
the opportunity to refocus on
the fact that that dilemma
between pride and humility
reappears as a question of
limits and transgressions with
the imagination and knowledge
and with love.
Of course, Dante would say that
there is such a thing of love
within--
with laws and yet love is one
of those experiences where we
usually don't like to believe
that there are limits,
right?
You don't want anybody to
come--I hope--to come to your
door and say,
I love you in a very reasonable
way and with a lot of
limitations.
I'm sure you'll give--kick him
out.
Love is one of those
experiences exactly like the
imagination,
that the powers of which seem
always to be transgressing
whatever limitations we want
to--
we wanted to transgress the
limitations,
rationally, reasonably we want
to impose on it.
This is the question that Dante
is raising.
You cannot have,
I think that you are--
you are onto the right track
with your--
in your paraphrasing the
whole--in your asking the
question that maybe
transgression and limitations
really have to be seen together.
Pride and humility will have to
be seen together;
subjection and freedom will
have to be seen together.
They are not terms which are so
far apart from each other.
Each involves the other,
that's why I call it a paradox,
the knot that joins these
things together,
is exactly that.
Is this--am I--did I confuse
all of you today here?
Oh my, then I will confuse you
next time.
Other questions that we have?
Yes.
Student:
Can you talk about the section
in Canto XV where he's talking
about how true love and the love
of God is like a mirror?
It's around line 70...
Prof: Canto XV.
Student:
Line 75...
Prof: Yes.
Student:
How love of God is like his
mirror that--the more people
that love God,
the more love he gives back and
it's like a mirror that keeps
reflecting and amplifying love.
And I was wondering--I was
intrigued by the image of the
mirror, so I was hoping that you
could talk a little bit about
how the image of the mirrors and
the idea of mirrors maybe are
part of Dante's way of thinking.
Prof: The--this is
around line 75,
right?
Let me just read this whole
paragraph.
Dante is in the--describing the
virtue that is opposed to envy,
mercy, the idea of--the notion
of mercy and because--I read
from 65 on:
"Because thou still
settest thy mind on earthly
things, thou gatherest darkness
from the very light."
That's part of--sort of
reversals that we--how light
induces and generates darkness;
it's a certain kind of light.
We seem to believe or to think
in terms of the light that is
available to us,
but that does not necessarily
produce more light,
but can dim our understanding
about the way things really are.
"That infinite and
unspeakable good which is there
above speeds to love as a
sunbeam comes to a bright body;
so much it gives of itself as
it finds ardor,
so the more charity extends the
more does the eternal goodness
increase upon it,
and the more souls that are
enamored there above the more
there are to be rightly loved
and the more love there is and
like a mirror the one returns it
to the other.
And if my speech do not relieve
thy hunger thou shalt see
Beatrice and she will deliver
thee wholly from this and every
other craving.
Strive only that soon may be
erased, as the other two are
already, the five wounds which
are healed by being
painful."
The question is,
you want me to say something
about the mirror,
the image of the mirror that is
being used here.
I think that this is a Platonic
image of the notion that all of
creation--this is The
Celestial Hierarchy of the
Pseudo-Dionysius.
I don't know that I have ever
spoken of him,
I will because Dante mentions
him in Paradise,
but in The Celestial
Hierarchy,
Dante--the
Pseudo-Dionysius--thinks of all
creation being a kind of
occasion--
being a kind of hall of mirrors
where everything is reflected
onto the other,
a number of reflections that
all give different light--
in different ways the light of
God,
this is so--that's where the
problem of mercy places us,
so this idea of charity.
Dante is interested in two
things, one the generative idea
of charity.
Charity produces more charity.
It has a kind of power to
generate itself and multiply
itself,
and the way he compares this
is--he compares it to what I
call--
what he calls here,
obliquely, the hall of mirrors.
Let me just say something else
about Pseudo-Dionysius,
when Pseudo-Dionysius wants
to--mystical theology--
he wants to talk about the
divine, he will think about the
divine in terms of light,
as you know.
Light that is refracted and
reflected throughout the orders
and ranks of creation.
The highest image of this light
of the divine is the sun.
The sun that is generous,
in the sense,
as I mean generous in a very
peculiar sense,
in the sense that it gives
itself to all,
without any distinction and it
depends on us,
whether we are going to be able
to appreciate that light or not,
but the sun is giving itself
freely to all.
This is the principle of mercy
for Dante.
Mirrors are reproducing that
light endlessly;
the whole of creation is
sending back this kind of light,
without any loss in itself of
the original light.
This is the metaphor and the
metaphysics of mirror in Dante.
The world is therefore,
from the point of view of
mercy, and not from the point of
view of envy,
where we do not even see the
light.
Envy means that we have no
knowledge of anything that comes
from the outside,
but in the world of mercy we
have an--
we understand this generous
giving of the light which comes
from God and the heat that goes
with it.
That's it, so it's a virtue
that completely offsets the
notion of envy,
the idea of God who creates
without envy,
that's another way of thinking
about the generosity of God.
That is connected to the light
and to the multiplications of
the light from mirrors.
Actually this is an image that
really reappears in
Paradise and we'll come
back to this canto,
the whole of Paradise organized
through this hall,
these infinite reflections of
God's light.